حج ذكي صوره مستقبليه ترسمها السعوديه
لمواسم الحج المقبله عبر مواكبه ثوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي فغرفه القياده والتحكم
التي تتابعها المديريه العامه للامن كانت
في المواسم الماضيه تعتمد على كاميرات
مراقبه حراريه وتغذيها بيانات ضخمه يتم
تمريرها يدويا لكن غرفه القياده خطط هذا
العام باتجاه التحول الرقمي وحفظ وتحليل
وتوظيف البيانات بموثوقيه عاليه بالتعاون
مع سدايا الخوارزميات التي بنيت بايااد
وعقول سعوديه وظفت لاول مره في المسجد
الحرام في مكه المكرمه واحد مخرجاتها
اداره الحشود وتنظيمها هذه الخوارزميات
تستهدف مراقبه حركه الحجيج وادار والعمليه
التنظيميه مع جهات حكوميه وغير حكوميه من
اجل ضمان سلامه الحجاج وسلاسه تنقلهم
واحده من الكاميرات الذكيه تراقب صحن
المطاف تسجل اعداد الاشخاص وتتعرفوا على
الوجوه وتعطي اشعارات عن ازدحام الاماكن
وايضا هدوءها الحاله الحمراء وصف للحاله
الطارئه توجب التدخل قبل وقوع الخطر في
المنطقه المركزيه في الحرم منصه اخرى سيتم
تطويرها لاحقا لرصد كثافه الزائرين في
المشاعر المقدسه اي في منى ومزدلفه وايضا
عرفات نظام سواهر يقرا مداخل مكه المكرمه
فيسجل عدد السيارات والاشخاص الداخلين
وايضا الخارجين ومقاصدهم وان كانوا يريدون
الحرم او مكه اما اللون الاصفر مثلا فيدل
على كثافه المشاه في مدينه من شرق مكه في
ايام التشريق الثلاث لرمي الجمرات فيما
مناطق اخرى ظهرت فارغه خريطه المؤشرات
مشاهدينا سيتم تطويرها بالتعاون مع سدايا
لرصد خصائص الحجاج والمعتمرين
وجنسياتهم وتفويجهم توظيف هذه التقنيات
بشكل كبير في غرفه العمليات يعني البدء
بمرحله تحول تشمل في المستقبل الشوارع
والتخطيط والتطوير وتخفيف الكوادر البشريه